[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Thank you.
In many ways, to
me, Google Cloud
is a natural extension
of our mission
to make information
accessible and useful.
We're just doing
it for businesses.
It means increasing
the availability
and lowering the cost of
data storage and computing
resources.
It means making it
easier for businesses
to understand and act
on critical information.
DIANE GREEN: Just to give you a
preview, we've got Disney here.
We've got our partner SAP.
We've got Colgate-Palmolive.
We've got Verizon.
We've got Home Depot.
We've got HSBC, one of
the world's largest banks.
And then we'll
close out with eBay
with a pretty wonderful demo.
MIKE WHITE: Currently, we
have about 500 projects
in the cloud.
That includes everything from
customer-facing or guest-facing
products in
production, we call it,
to dev to QA to our
R&D environments,
and also all of our data suites
are running out of BigQuery.
BERND LEUKERT: Today we are
delighted to announce here
in San Francisco the
general availability of SAP
HANA on Google Cloud platform.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE CROWE: In one
weekend in November,
we took more than
20,000 users live.
So all told, more than
28,000 users in six months.
90% of our users are
active on Google Drive.
And in February alone, we
had more than 57,000 hours
of video Hangouts.
DIANE GREEN: So I
understand you're
going to start moving
150,000 Verizon workers.
What were you looking for?
ALIN D'SILVA: So we did a
comprehensive trial of G Suite,
and our employees
really loved it.
They loved the simplicity
and intuitiveness
of the product, the ease of use.
The real-time collaboration
really blew them away.
PAUL GAFFNEY:
Thinking differently
about resiliency and
availability, moving from,
I think, what's a classical big
company IT orientation, which
is make the infrastructure
robust, to a more modern view
that says, just assume that
everything's going to fail.
And that was a big
catalyst for us
to engineer our software
differently and partner
with you guys on learning what
does it mean to live in a world
where you make your stuff
resilient to failure?
DARRYL WEST: We're a bank.
At the core of our
business, we're a bank.
But we also have a significant
technology company embedded
within the organization.
And the question that I was
asking the management team
is, do we really want to
compete with the cloud providers
and people like Google?
Are we really
going to try and do
what they do as
well as they do it?
RJ PITTMAN: In five months,
we went from nothing
to the entire one
billion live listings
of eBay running in GCP.
It was not a test.
It was not a prototype.
It quickly moved to a
production-grade environment
for us that we ended up
launching and bringing
in to market six months
ahead of our plan.
FEI-FEI LI: We've
often considered
videos the dark matter
of the digital universe.
Today, I'm very excited to
announce an entirely new API
powered by machine intelligence,
the video intelligence API.
What we need is a more
scalable and effective way
to democratize data.
That's why I'm thrilled to
make the next announcement--
Google Cloud's
acquisition of Kaggle.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHMIDT: If you leave
the infrastructure to us,
we put $30 billion--
and I know because I
approved it, so it's real--
into this platform.
Please do not attempt
to duplicate it.
You have better
uses of your money.
[MUSIC PLAYING]